I think that we still live in a society
where we fundamentally think that we are
separate from other people that we are
sort of isolated minds that exists in
isolated bodies that are fundamentally
distinct from the other minds and bodies
that we see in the world and I don't
want to get too philosophical but I
think that a lot of this does have its
roots in the sort of Western
philosophical tradition started starting
with Descartes positing that we that the
eye is fundamentally separate from the
world that I in the world are two
completely distinct categories that
cannot be unified with each other so I
think a psychedelics can really help to
promote a sort of mindset in which that
apparent boundary breaks down where we
really do see ourselves as a part of the
world rather than as separate from it
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still in Cambridge in Massachusetts
we are now going to be talking about
psychedelics consciousness and the
cosmos we have Kenneth shinozuka and JJ
Andrade joining us on the show hello
guys hey thanks so much for having us
it's great to be here I'm super pumped
to talk to you both
I'm really excited we have a lot to
unpack about these three topics and so
much more for those that don't know
Kenneth shinozuka and JJ Andrade are
cofounders of Harvard undergraduate
science of psychedelics Club which is
dedicated to an interdisciplinary
philosophically motivated and
scientifically rigorous study of
psychedelics and more broadly
consciousness and you can find all of
their links in the bio below and you can
join their mailing list as well
alright guys let's start things off with
our favorite question that we like
asking we love asking people we find
ourselves as stewards of earth what is
your current take on the state of
humanity yeah so I think it's great to
situate this question in the context of
this Allen Watts
rotation that I once heard which is
something like I'm paraphrasing here
that the universe is becoming aware of
itself through our own eyes I can't
speak as much about the state of
humanity in terms of society culture and
politics but I think that this is a good
place to start for me and the reason is
it I think that we're in the rare point
of human history where we really are
becoming aware of both ourselves and
also the universe and the universe truly
is I think becoming aware of itself
through our own consciousness we're at a
rare point where we can really
understand the past of humanity the
history of humanity and also the past of
the cosmos and where it might be heading
and I think probably the place where
we're making the most progress at least
on our awareness of ourselves is perhaps
through neuroscience we're becoming
incredibly aware of how how our own
brains function and therefore I think
we're really at a point where we're
becoming very very aware of ourselves in
a way that humanity wasn't thousands of
years ago when we didn't have the tools
to understand our own brains yeah very
exciting point in the saga of humanity
I'm perhaps a little bit more nervous I
think than Kenneth about the current
state of humanity
I think globally we're seeing you know
skyrocketing inequality a decline in
political liberalism and an increase in
political authoritarianism and
reactionary beliefs so those are some of
the destruction of the environment those
are some things that I'm very nervous
about for the future of Manatee but I do
think there are reasons to be optimistic
that those may might be a local minima
instead of the end of of our
civilization the psychedelic Renaissance
that's going on right now and in
scientific research I think is as we're
going to be talking about later a huge
development that could meaningfully
change a lot of those things as you're
talking about
I think breakthroughs in a lot of fields
of science from anti-aging to
neuroscience are really going to change
the way that we understand ourselves and
the way that we understand how human
societies should function so I think we
are definitely at a critical moment in
our history and it is up to us to decide
whether that's going to be critically
positive or critically negative good on
both of your ends the you went really
deep into the current state of things
you went on this really big scale of
things with a really deep awakening of
the universe becoming aware of itself
that was good I like like you guys are
kind of like yin and yang in that a
little bit oh so that was good I was
good let's get to the journeys so
Kenneth your background is very
interesting Kenneth has a powerful
three-minute video online of him at CES
from 2016 where he he founded a company
called safe wander and interestingly
enough it's due to one of his family
members having dementia and that got you
interested in neuroscience and
consciousness and so I want you to
unpack a little bit of that for us and
then we'll do JJ's afterward yeah
absolutely so I I grew up in a
three-generation household so I was very
close to my grandparents when I was
growing up my grandfather got dementia
when I was four years old and growing up
with him I was constantly exposed to the
challenges of taking care of him
we decided my family decided to take
care of my grandfather at her home and
as his condition progressed he started
wandering out of bed at night when my
mother and I moved to New York City in
the summer of 2012
my grandfather was wandering out of bed
at least once per night and this put a
lot of stress on my aunt who was taking
care of him at the time because she had
to stay awake all night to keep an eye
on him and even then often failed to
catch him leaving the bed so I invented
this device in high school called a safe
wander which would notify caregivers
whenever dementia patients got up out of
the bed at night and eventually ended up
commercializing the product and it's now
currently selling online and we've been
able to help over a thousand dementia
patients with our device so when I was
applying to college I was think
that I was going to study neuroscience
that I could tackle the problem of
dementia Alzheimer's is I think the only
major disease at least in the United
States that has no cure treatment or
prevention so it's a huge huge inning MA
we really don't have that much of an
idea of how to tackle it then I
underwent a pretty major shift the
summer before I went to college I had
this period of great existential
uncertainty and it was during this time
that I found this book called the power
of now which very radically transformed
my views on on life and my place in the
universe as well through the power of
now I got very interested in questions
about consciousness which are also
inextricably linked to psychedelics and
after reading the book I decided that I
wanted to study consciousness not only
in college but also for the rest of my
life so I am still doing research on
Alzheimer's currently at the
Massachusetts General Hospital which is
affiliated with the Harvard Medical
School and my ultimate passion though is
to study consciousness which i think is
the greatest cinema in the universe oh
and I should also say that I've also
been documenting sort of my progress in
my thinking through this blog that I
started back in the fall of 2017 which
is called blank horizons which you can
find at blank horizons calm so epic love
the story and there's just so much cool
there's the ability for us to be able to
see how you came to where you did today
through your journey I think is quite
evident and sometimes it's it can be
hard to find that and but you it's it's
very clear and that's that's really
beautiful and I'm your hardest at enigma
in the yeah in the universe that's so
interesting with consciousness Wow
all right and then JJ's background
with science and religion from a young
age and now is super fascinating with
biophysics was just taking him really
deep into consciousness and psychedelics
oh yeah give us that sure yeah so
probably my first major interest was
religion from the time I was very young
I was originally very fascinated with
Eastern religions you know like yogic
philosophies Buddhism Taoism especially
as there in Qin for a while and then
over time that also became an interest
in Western religions the monastic
traditions in Christianity and the
mystical traditions in like orthodoxy
and Catholicism and you know Sufism in
Islam things like that Kabbalah lism in
Judaism and then as I I grew older I
also developed a very intense interest
in science specially biology and physics
because to me
physics answered you know somewhat
similar questions to what religion was
trying to answer what is the underlying
order and structure to what's going on
around us and I found that physics could
answer those questions in ways that were
testable and study Bowl and that was
really very appealing to me so I decided
when I went to college that I was going
to study physics and a quote of
Einstein's that really resonates with me
sort of in that way is I want to know
the mind of God and the rest are just
details and as I sort of went through my
oh well for that reason when people
would ask me like oh but don't like what
do you want to do with that I would say
like oh I just want to study the
extremely abstract theoretical stuff and
I don't care if it ever helps the world
that was very naive take that I used to
have I don't believe that anymore and
that's partially why as I've I've grown
older I've switched my focus more
towards biophysics both because one
biology is a subject that I have loved
for a very long time and two I think
it's an area that is more able to have a
positive impact on the human condition
and that's something that's been
increasingly important to me and yeah so
I'm still very interested in religion I
still take a lot of Religious Studies
classes at Harvard and I still spend a
good chunk of my time studying various
mystical traditions and stuff like that
and practicing myself but as far as
career go
I have decided to go in the scientific
direction because I think that's the
better way to make an impact on the
world the passing time studying on
what's been around thousands of years
finding meaning in life and then taking
it on a scientific trying to probe at
the code of the world around us is yeah
it's it's interesting you guys
co-founding this work together I want I
want before we get there I want to know
your thoughts you guys worked really
really hard to get into Harvard it's
very difficult to get into Harvard
Harvard is also a it's a very prominent
academic institution with a lot of smart
people here around you at the same time
it's also an undergraduate zoo in many
ways it's just the same type of
behaviors as we see at other collegiate
campuses what is how do you feel about
you know we spent some time talking to
Julia Shea about the architecture of the
dormitories and how it's you know that
that and the amount of of there's not
really the one-on-one apprenticeship in
the bloom to Sigma how you can perform
two standard deviations above the
control if you have one apprentice right
all this type of type of stuff if you
have a mentor and you're an apprentice
so it's just like what are your current
thoughts on the state of your
experiences at Harvard I have really I'm
graduating May so this is a very timely
question for me so this month and I've
really really loved my time at Harvard
I think I'm it was so fortunate to be
able to have a group of friends and a
community of people who no matter what
my interests were at no matter if I want
to talk about policy economics physics
biology there was always someone who I
could find who would be willing to talk
about those things with me for you know
hours upon hours without ever growing
sick of it and I think that's a very
rare thing to find in a lifetime
and that's something I'm extremely
grateful for of course like a lot of
people probably have the concept of
Harvard that is filled with you know
rich elitist people those people are
there I just don't you know associate
myself with them very much and
there are a lot of extremely passionate
extremely driven people and that's the
best part Department it's not the
classes although those are great it is
the community of people that you find
yourself in yeah yeah
so I had a pretty different experience
from JJ at least for the first two years
that I was at Harvard
Simon jr. now I'm at the end of my third
year I was initially actually very
dissatisfied with Harvard I was pretty
confident that I was going to take a
leave of absence for about two years or
maybe even drop out after my sophomore
year ended and I think that
dissatisfaction largely stemmed from the
fact that I really had a lot of
difficulty finding people who were
interested in the same topics that I was
namely consciousness spirituality and
the sort of intersection of that and
neuroscience and physics and philosophy
and ultimately though through
co-founding the science of psychedelics
Club I was able to find a really great
community of people JJ included who are
interested in these topics and so I'm
incredibly grateful to have found those
people on campus to speak a little more
to your to your point Allen about how
Harvard much like other colleges is very
much a zoo there are truly some crazy
opportunities that you get to have
through Harvard so I'm part of this
acapella group called the Crocodylus
which I joined my sophomore year every
year the Crocodylus Crocs for short
embark on this summer tour where we
travel all around the world usually to
Asia Australia Europe and maybe a couple
of other continents and the the tour is
entirely paid for through the revenue
that we make with concerts and so it's
basically an all-expenses-paid tour for
us we get to travel around the world
young people and and although we have to
do is sing it's an incredible incredible
opportunity and I'm really grateful that
I was able to have that through Harvard
and you are right that Harvard I think a
lot of people assume that the people at
Harvard don't really party on that they
aren't really as social as say people at
other colleges and I think while it's
true that Harvard certainly doesn't have
as much of a party culture as other
schools people do get crazy at this
institution without a doubt and you know
I mean like 18 to 22 year olds are gonna
be 18 to 22 year olds yeah yeah
interesting it's it's cool how both of
you found the community here to be such
a valuable thing and that it's a it is
in very many ways a funnel of towards
some of the smartest people in the world
and so it makes a lot of sense yeah and
yeah yeah it's it's crazy
thinking about your ability to be able
to go from finding such little meaning
Kenneth first two years to being able to
be like I found what I was looking for
that's so if we can get more of the
doors open for young people to be able
to find that meaning at young ages so
that they don't you know drop out but
that they keep going and find the right
people to surround themselves with that
they find interest in so you two found
each other and the cofounders as the
Harvard undergraduate science of
psychedelics Club short for will do
psychedelics Club for short or science
of psychedelics Club for short yes yes
and the big why here let's get to this
big why it makes sense with biophysics
and neuroscience and consciousness you
guys both are obviously even the melting
pot of those fields so give us the big
why on the club yeah so I guess first
I'll give it a little bit of history
about the club there were sort of two
independent streams of thought that
coincided with each other
so a friend of mine Andrew Zuckerman and
I wanted to create the Harvard
consciousness Club this was sort of
around the time this was a last semester
my fall semester of my junior year when
I realized that I wanted to create my
own social group on campus to really be
able to delve deeply into these
questions about consciousness and so
Andrew and I were thinking about
starting this Harvard consciousness Club
around the same time JJ was a filing
filing for official approval for the
Harvard science of psychedelics Club
JJ Zach Andrew goes for Zach for short
JJ Zack and I realized that we had a lot
of mutual shared interests in the sort
of intersection of psychedelics and
consciousness so we decided to merge
into the Harvard undergraduate science
of psychedelics club and we've been
hosting meetings since February of this
year so we're only less than 3 months
old right now
the big y phenomenal question I mean for
me I'm principally interested in this
vast ending m'a of what consciousness is
I think psychedelics right now are the
primary tool that we have for readily
and I suppose easily accessing altered
states of consciousness we also have
deep meditative practices that can lead
to altered states but oftentimes a great
deal of training and practice is
necessary in order to in order to access
those states of consciousness through
meditation
I think psychedelics are an easy and
also I guess accessible tool for
accessing at those states yeah quick
disclaimer the we're not encouraging the
irresponsible use of any of these
psychedelic substances at all because
there are very strong substances they
are contraindicated for certain groups
of people like people with schizophrenia
and and other bipolar
for instance the it's not understood how
they interact with these things and
till it is understood it's probably good
idea to be risk-averse in that way also
traditionally these substances when
they've been used in indigenous
communities like I have wasps gut and
peyote and stuff like that they are used
with a very conscientious vehicle
they're used in ritual fashion they are
used with a guide with them and that has
always been considered a very important
aspect of their usage so do not just
kind of go crazy like off the wall with
with these powerful substances so I'll
give also just a bit of history about
what happened served before the two
clubs became one I've always been very
interested in the 60s in the
counterculture and the values that
people were trying to spread at those
times and the music very close to my
heart the music from that time and so I
was reading a book called the Harvard
psychedelics club about the sort of
counterculture crew at Harvard in the
60s that really helped launch the
psychedelic involvement in the
counterculture who were Timothy Leary
and Richard Alpert who would later
become Ram Dass after I'm going to India
and pursuing spirituality in that way so
I was reading that book and I found it
very interesting it maybe want to get
more into sort of the history and at
this point I didn't really realize how
important psychedelics in my opinion now
are are I saw that there's a conference
in New York called the horizons
psychedelic science of psychedelics
conference they do this every year I
thought that's interesting I'll go see
what that's about
so I went to that and it's essentially
conference they present all of the
modern clinical research going on
psychedelics because if if your viewers
aren't familiar after the 60s
psychedelic tribe and because of the you
know the craziness that occurred
although it's probably not so much
because of the craziness that occurred
as it was because of the threat to the
power structures that the counterculture
and the anti-war movement was causing so
it was banned they were banned
completely not just for consumption but
for study even though they were being
studied for a wide variety of illnesses
with incredible effectiveness alcoholism
depression all sorts of you know all
addictions really nicotine addiction
so in the early 2000s that ice finally
melted and the first new research on
psychedelics started and I didn't know
any of this until I went to this
conference and the conference showed
just such remarkable of results for
treating PTSD and so many of these
diseases that are not improving in the
modern world mental illness our
treatments for mental illnesses are not
getting much better SSRIs are only
somewhat better than placebo centering
depression for instance and then that
immediately made me recognize that this
was going to be a very important an
important thing to get rid of the stigma
around these medicines and let people
engage with them rationally and
scientifically also I came across a
study showing that use of psychedelics
is correlated with increased politically
liberal attitudes increased
anti-authoritarian attitudes increased
um concern or sense of stewardship
toward the environment and really
importantly an increase in trade
openness with the personality trait of
openness which they've never discovered
other substances being able to alter
these personality traits after the age
of 20 or something like that and when I
saw that I realized that the unive these
problems I list in the beginning I
ultimately in my opinion art can be
drawn back to the fact that people are
not open enough and so that was the real
trigger for me to be like okay I need to
create an official body to get this
going and after a lot of effort trying
to find advisor to the club people were
very hesitant to be official advisers
for this club at the college I was able
to formally start the science of
psychedelics Club then during that
process I connected with Kenneth and
Zach and that has sort of led to where
we are now so that's that's the
backstory there yeah yeah yeah there's
there's a lot there all right on a on a
very deeply spiritual and conscious and
a side of things we have with
consciousness being this massive enigma
we have on a spiritual oneness unity
side there's a lot of geopolitical
pressures and power pressures preventing
since the 60s
this type of
women from coming to fruition hit a Sun
on on a little bit on that I want to
hear your thoughts on that on just like
why that has happened why there was this
kind of backlash and stuff like that
give us give us an idea of of both why
from why why since the 60s was there the
view of the influence of psychedelics
causing openness and that potentially
causing some of the more openness in
geopolitics and that's a good thing and
then let's lead that up until 2020
really until around now and where we see
openness and geopolitics heading in the
future so I think a lot of people don't
understand the degree to which like the
psychedelic cycles leaving the
laboratory and entering into you know
recreational consumption with the youth
of that time contributed to the the
movements that were happening in that
time you can see it in the music you can
see it in the clothes people were
wearing you can see it in the spiritual
traditions people were embracing much to
their parents chagrin they'd the total
transformation of values from their
parents generation and the sense of
unity that they call that they tend to
cultivate during these experiences the
sense of oneness with other human beings
the sense of transcending yourself and
your like your national ties and so on
that was a huge spark for the anti-war
movement and the anti-war movement was a
huge thorn in Richard Nixon side and one
of the ways that they found that they
could interrupt these movements was by
tackling these substances so they passed
laws to I mean this is more or less on
record now Richard Nixon an aide of
Richard Nixon's has provided a quote
saying that they banned they they
started the initial ban of these drugs
so that they could not just psychedelics
but also a heroin and cannabis and
others so that they could interrupt
specifically the civil rights movement
and the anti-war movement so the
political implications of these
substances are not small I I think that
they were a large
and sort of the unrest in a positive way
there needed to be unrest at that time
because we were fighting an unethical
war we were not thinking about the real
impact of our actions on the global
future and so these things were
cultivating an unrest that powers at
that time we're not comfortable with and
that was a large reason why their
crackdown yeah and then in 2020 now I
think the eye 2020 now is not going to
be too different from 60s then I don't
think I mean obviously we're in a
different culture now that's somewhat
less repressive it is somewhat less
hostile towards new idea as an openness
which is it's good but it is not
obviously a perfectly open society or a
perfectly loving society or a perfectly
unified society so those same things
when those ideas try to force their way
into a world that has not embraced them
yet it there will be repercussions of
that especially because they make people
skeptical of hierarchy that make people
I mean I shouldn't say they make people
but they tend to make people more
skeptical of hierarchy they tend to make
people more concerned with the
environment which of course is now an
even more pressing issue than it was in
the 60s so I think the I don't think
there is going to be another sort of
widespread use of them amongst like a
counterculture for a number of reasons
but even just the therapeutic use of
them which is what will probably legal
it'd be legalized in the near future
will help transform people's attitudes
on all of these topics because they will
help people I think be a more
open-minded which is the crucial part of
it yeah I don't know if you have
anything to yeah yeah I can't speak as
much to the current geopolitical
situation of the world is JJ can just
because of my lack of knowledge in that
department
but what I will say is that I think that
there are three aspects of psychedelic
experience that are worth noting in
relation to JJ's comment about openness
number one is ego death so a sort of
sense of dissolution of self
number two is a sense of oneness with
other people and with the world
generally and also humanity and third I
think is just a sense of awe wonder and
compassion and those three are all
linked to each other they aren't really
three separate aspects of psychedelic
experiences if you have a really
profound psychedelic experience all
three of those things could happen to
you in one trip what I will say about
society right now is that I think that
we still live in a society where we
fundamentally think that we are separate
from other people that we are sort of
isolated minds that exist in isolated
bodies that are fundamentally distinct
from the other minds and bodies that we
see in the world and I don't want to get
too philosophical but I think that a lot
of this does have its roots in the sort
of Western philosophical tradition
started starting with Descartes positing
that we that the eye is fundamentally
separate from the world that I in the
world are two completely distinct
categories that cannot be unified with
each other so I think a psychedelics can
really help to promote a sort of mindset
in which that apparent boundary breaks
down where we really do see ourselves as
a part of the world rather than as
separate from it yes yes yes just quick
on both your points there that were sued
over so good we had both the importance
of actually today hopefully having the
widespread use of of technology that is
in our pockets now can hopefully
catalyze the oneness revolution faster
hopefully now I think it's quite
possible that we could get there plus
all of the the transit that we're making
towards the legalization and the
medicinal use so hopefully we can we can
get there and then yes the ego death the
feelings of oneness these are so
critical and then
the yeah the e the separation illusion
of separation so this is a very
interesting bounce because we have to
keep ourselves there has to be some ego
to function yeah and then there also has
to be some ego to dissolve otherwise too
much of the ego can drive us to a point
of losing touch with the ecosystems of
other humans and the planet that we live
in so yeah ginger you wanted to say some
stuff I was just gonna add one kind of
amusing anecdote about how powerful
politically people involved within the
counterculture boom in the 60s
I thought these substances were was I
learned this in the documentary of the
sunshine makers which is about Nick
sands and Tim Scully who were two of the
chemists and synthesizing the vast
majority of the LSD during the
counterculture movement in the 60s and
they had a very concerted effort to
synthesize first of all they produced a
lot of this for free because they felt
that they were doing it as a way to
change the world not as a way to make
money which is an interesting fact but
they very much wanted to get their
product behind the the iron wall the
wall the USSR essentially they wanted to
get as much of their of their
psychedelics that they're producing into
the USSR because they felt that it could
cultivate an anti-authoritarian
perspective that would lead to the
crumbling of these authoritarian regimes
and end the Cold War and they believed
that that was like a very crucial
political objective that their work was
moving towards yeah how crazy would that
be to drop a bunch of LSD in the Middle
East you know drop oh yeah I drop a
bunch of LSD in North Korea and in
you know this is hard to it's hard to
say though because there's so many
issues with the the geopolitics you
can't just you know drop it into
Venezuela and be like it's gonna sort
itself out it's uh but but at the same
time it's it's funny you know when you
think about the United Nations and when
you think about working with them on a
little micro dose at the General
Assembly you know what would happen
right what would happen with a little
meditation plus a micro dose and some
met at some some Tibetan singing bowls
and some yeah yeah I mean I mean one
idea that I've thought about facetiously
is what would happen if you got Donald
Trump Kim jong-un Bashar al-assad and
other leaders of the world to all trip
acid at the same time I mean and have it
on video I mean it's never gonna happen
right but justjust just imagine just
imagine it's gonna happen we're gonna
we're gonna get there you think 2020 is
crazy right but just wait couple more
years down the line Gen Z are gonna be
roaring with their technology and
they're gonna be relentless with their
pushes towards this oneness and their
kid and that this just it's just gonna
keep and the kids that are born that
I've only known the Internet is some
crazy stuff and just their ability to
communicate about things that matter to
them I think could potentially catalyze
that geopolitical oneness that we we so
desperately need but then we have to
balance in the competition right the
innovation and the competition you still
want people to be able to like compete
for the edge of science yeah I was just
gonna say we of course weren't the first
people to have thought of what if all
the world leaders had this experience of
oneness Allen Ginsberg the beat poet the
first time he was administered LSD by
Timothy Leary he he said oh my god this
was before the hippy movement he said
we're gonna start a movement it's me
based on love and peace and unity and
then he tried to get timothy leary to
get Mau on the phone he said call up Mau
I'm gonna tell him that we're doing
peace now yeah that's a very funny story
about Allen Ginsberg's a takeaway from
it which really did foreshadow the the
years that were just about to follow
those early the early sixties people did
not know what was going to happen in the
late sixties yet I really just I have
such a I have a strong desire to want to
talk about this in terms of breaking
down hierarchies that there's a lot of
competence in hierarchies right you can
even make a hierarchy of spirituality
and say that who are the spiritual
leaders right they've practiced the most
meditation connection all that is
whatever but then there's also
competence hierarchies okay those that
have brought forth maybe the most
reductions of suffering great you can
frame competence in different ways but
then you can also talk about it money
right there's 1500 billionaires and
they're at the top right so to be able
to take yeah Davos or the UN or whoever
is at the top of this power hierarchy
and be able to get a change in unity but
keep competition roaring and innovation
at the edge of science is something that
is really crucial to catalyze you guys
have done you know nine events now in
just the last three months everything
from a Zen monk and a psycho not
speaking and that was about 150 people
were there all the way to Rick Doblin
talking from maps all the way to
holotropic breathwork so teach us about
kind of what the road map is like
building this community and what the
experience has been with it sure yeah I
think I think I speak for all the
founders who Andrews not here when I say
that we were surprised very pleasantly
surprised that we had such a big
community turnout for our first event
like you said about 150 we were very
pleased to see that we didn't realize
that there was that much interest on
campus and in the in the Boston area so
I think the road map for this club
really because we didn't just do this
because we wanted to talk to other
people about this thing I think we all
had
that largely overlapped but weren't
identical but at least for me one of the
large goals is to get the this science
that people are worst uh deaiing take
more seriously and Harvard since it was
one of the first places where these
things really left the lab and Timothy
Leary and Rahm das were both fired from
their positions at Harvard their
professors there
I think symbolically getting it taken
seriously again at Harvard getting
ideally scientific research on the topic
jump started again at Harvard would be a
huge victory if that's what comes from
the club that would be something that I
am very proud of yeah yeah totally
completely second everything that JJ
said I think it would be wonderful if we
could get more psychedelic research in
academia psychedelics are such an
understudied topic given the tremendous
amount of potential they have I mean I
very strongly believe that there is so
much that we can learn about the brain
from a more advanced study of
psychedelics I mean we've really only
just even begun to scratch the surface
and this is primarily due to the many
decades in which psychedelics were
accessible to the public but just were
not researched due to the primarily due
to the stigma associated with it many
universities were not willing to fund
research on psychedelics so we're just
now starting to see research on
psychedelics being done at institutions
like Yale Johns Hopkins there's a lot of
promising research going on in the UK I
believe the Center for psychedelic
research was just established at the
yeah at last last week at the Imperial
College London yeah
to my knowledge Harvard still doesn't
really have any ongoing research on at
least on at least the scientific effects
of psychedelics it would be wonderful to
see more researchers here at Harvard
doing work on psychedelics yeah I see
your you know your roadmap is a lot of
just really wanting to push the not only
the edge of psychedelics but also get
the public more engaged in how the
importance of it for consciousness for
neuroscience for spirituality for
oneness like I love that a lot about you
guys that you guys can really feel that
from you in the way that you
communicated and I'm looking forward to
what you build I want to have you guys
tackle a question that is very similar
but both of you tackling from a
different way for Kenneth from an edge
of the enigma that is consciousness what
are some of your best guess is and for
JJ what makes matter living versus not
living this is a huge question and one
that I'm not sure that I can do
sufficient justice to in the span of a
short interview what I will say is that
the debate about consciousness at least
in philosophical circles has primarily
boiled down to two competing worldviews
there are the materialists who argue
that consciousness is a product of brain
activity there are some philosophers who
will even venture so far as to say that
consciousness is just an illusion
sometimes they use the word
epiphenomenon which means that is sort
of just like a secondary byproduct of
brain activity that doesn't really have
any sort of causal influence and then on
the other hand you have idealists who
argue that really everything is just
sort of a sort of a projection of your
own consciousness on that there is no
external world that is indivisible from
your own consciousness and I suppose
implicitly having grown up in a
community of pretty materialist
scientists both of my parents were civil
engineers I guess I implicitly subscribe
to the materialist worldview although I
didn't really think much about it and
then after reading the power of now and
exposing myself to a lot of ideas in
Eastern spirituality I became much more
receptive to the idealist view and these
are deep philosophical questions for
which is hard to find much of a
resolution I I guess right now I'm
attracted to two big views the first
is pen psychism which holds that
everything is conscious so there's this
sort of huge chasm I think between the
material physical activity that is
happening in the brain and subjective
conscious experience for me at least
it's incredibly difficult to see how you
could get subjective experience from the
activity of neurons no matter how
complex and highly organized they are I
think one of the ways of resolving this
issue is to believe that everything has
a conscious experience at some
fundamental level how exactly that's the
case it's it's very hard to work out and
it's certainly a very controversial view
the second major view that I'm attracted
to is this idea called a dual aspect
monism and this basically tries to say
well maybe it's misguided to try to boil
down the universe to either purely
physical things or purely mental things
maybe the physical and the mental are
just two opposite sides of the same coin
and you ask you know what is that one
coin it's also another big question for
me I'm sort of inclined to believe that
there's something akin to a universal
consciousness that everything is
participating in on that the universe is
one sort of vast intelligence or
consciousness that we really can't quite
comprehend except perhaps through
mystical and spiritual experiences that
can be accessed through meditation
psychedelics and yeah so I guess those
are the questions that I'm thinking
about primarily right now so your
question was what sort of distinguishes
living matter from nonliving matter that
is a big open question in the area of
biophysics that I'm most interested in
doing research in after I graduate it's
not understood we don't know the answer
to why or some systems living because I
mean when we say why are they living we
mean that these living systems have very
unique properties you know these complex
systems have self organizations
spontaneous self organization they have
coherent energy transfer over long
distances in ways that we have not been
able to create synthetically and so
there's a lot of open questions about
what physical and mathematical
suppose underlie these systems that we
call living and how do they work how can
we take advantage of that can we use
them to make our own living things
without actually needing it to come from
other living things and that would have
a lot of repercussions unlike our
understanding of how life started for
instance if we understand what life is
we have a much clearer idea of where we
can narrow down where to explore for its
origins so I'll give you an example of
some of the different like ways people
think about living matter in terms of as
physics when you have say water there's
when and you exposed certain pressures
and certain temperatures and stuff it
can convert to ice and that's what we
call a phase transition and people now
we're doing research on phase
transitions in living matter which would
be like what sort of effective
temperatures would it's not an actual
temperature but some an analogy to the
physical concept of temperature in the
living in a biological system causes it
to undergo phase transitions and one
would be like there's a certain like
phase of the bulk material of the living
system that is say homeostatic so
nothing's going on and it's just kind of
how living tissue normally is and then
if it undergoes this bulk phase
transition maybe it has to do with the
water maybe has to do with the like the
the electronic structure of proteins or
something in the cell then that can
trigger change in the physical
properties of diffusion stuff throughout
that shifts the whole functionality of
the system towards maybe inflammation
and maybe cellular proliferation and
then it might undergo a phase transition
back after that is no longer necessary
so they do seem to be sort of physical
principles that biological systems
manipulate in order to cause these
physical transformations on sort of a
small scale that's a very interesting
active area of research and like I said
we don't know the answers to how these
living systems are different from
nonliving systems but there's definitely
a lot of interesting research going on
and if once we do understand say this
phase transition idea this idea that it
you can map these physical concepts on
to the biological concept they're going
on it opens a question of can we use
that to treat disease maybe a chronic
state of like cancer is a chronic state
of cellular proliferation
maybe we can find ways to modify the the
book like statistical structure and the
book physics going on in the cells to
move away from that which is an area
that we is still very speculative and we
have no idea about really hmm
yeah these are these are great answers
at young ages for tackling hard hard
some of the hardest challenges that we
face I do have a strong tendency to feel
the most connected to all that is and
feeling the oneness through meditation
through psychedelics and when I do that
I think and feel that we need to help
more people feel this because then that
can get us closer to that unity if the
children that are born also dive deeper
into that feeling as well and that's a
whole nother conversation about what age
do we think these potentially
psychedelic experiences are good to come
in at how to titrate things like that
how to do with the psychotherapists all
these types of things there's all those
all those questions and also on a on a I
wonder just on a quick note on on face
change I'm just I'm interested to see if
if there's potentially a way to call a
awareness expansion a face change that
could be very interesting yeah thoughts
there is some cool sigh I'm a big fan of
trying to use like the analogies of
statistical mechanics and with
biophysics is not exactly an analogy
since there is non equilibrium
statistical thermodynamics going on in
these systems and we don't understand
how that works but in other things it is
more of an analogy like trying to
understand one example would be like in
there are certain bacterial colonies
where they've discovered what they can
call an effective temperature based on
like the back-and-forth motion of the
bacteria and stuff like that just like
with particles and through this effect
of temperature they can predict phase
transitions of these bacterial colonies
well though under a certain effective
temperature though
you see coalesce into spohrer form which
is like ice and above a certain factor
temperature they will melt and become
sort of more like a fluid so there are a
lot of interesting analogies here and
they've done this kind of analogical
thinking with simple mechanics in the
brain thinking about the brain as an
entropic like the number of novel states
that the brain can reach from a Givens
brain state would be considered roughly
the entropy of that brain state and so
if your brain isn't a sort of highly
creative a lot of possibilities that the
brain can enter into from a given state
it's in a highly entropic State and
there's a lot of work or then they would
call that the effective temperature a
low temperature brain would be something
that cannot access through many novel
States from its current state there's a
lot of work trying to talk about
psychedelics in terms of how they raise
this temperature of the brain or they
they increase the entropy in the brain
and thinking about certain diseases
particularly OCD depression and all
manner of addictions as conditions where
the brain is not too high entropy but
too low entropy it gets fixed in two
states that cannot reach new States it
gets essentially trapped in the currents
a is frozen if you want to continue on
with that low-temperature analogy and
psychedelics are sort of able to break
up that that low entropy state and allow
them to reach new experiences that
they've been shut out of since they've
developed these illnesses and that's
actually thought to be one of the
central reasons why it's so effective
for this specific category of diseases a
remarkably effective for this specific
category disease I know for nicotine in
preliminary trials they had an 80%
quitting rate which is enormous compared
to the quitting rate of people given
just placebo in depression it's been
shown to have remarkably effective
results much more than any any other
medicine that we've really discovered
and it's probably because the brain is
just stuck and if it can't get out it
can't undergo this phase transition out
of its current state essentially
so I'm so so happy that we got to this
to this last part on that that's getting
the mind to face transition to two
states of awareness that can alleviate
suffering that can augment our awareness
towards oneness I mean these are some of
the most crucial things that we could be
studying and we are not doing it enough
just scratching for now the surface it
is scratching okay guys two quick
questions on the way out are we in a
simulation this is also an incredibly
difficult question to tackle what I okay
so I what I will say is that the
universe is very very finely tuned it
seems for the conditions of life so in
order for the universe to have begun in
the smooth arrangement of matter that it
consisted of immediately after the Big
Bang I believe the the physicist Roger
Penrose once calculated that there was a
1 in 10 to the power of 10 to the power
of 123 chance that the universe was in
that smooth arrangement of matter
immediately after the Big Bang other
conditions in the universe like the
constants that mediate a lot of the
fundamental forces in the universe are
very very finely tuned for life if you
had altered them by say 0.001 units then
intelligent life could have never
emerged we do seem to live in a universe
that in some way seems to have been
designed for intelligent life now this
gets into many questions about you know
whether the universe was intelligently
designed a lot of people are pretty
reluctant to accept that idea
so I'm not gonna pause it that there was
any sort of external force that did sort
of that did design life in the way that
it did but it seems to be a very curious
feature of the initial conditions in
which the universe began that they were
so so specific and perhaps specific in
such a way that they did lead to
intelligent life so I think that
probably the most compelling argument
for the idea that we do live in a
simulation is this fact that the
universe is so finely tuned for life in
the sense that all of our experience is
internally generated and that our brain
is you know constantly sampling reality
and then making an inference about what
it must be like which is highly relevant
to psychedelics interestingly because
it's thought that maybe those somehow
interrupt that process and so there's a
lot more sort of the inferences become a
lot more less correlated so like the
your brain will infer more distant
concepts from its current state
essentially so in the sense that we are
constantly sampling and inferring about
reality and that we're not actually
looking at reality we're looking at what
our brain is filling in the details
we are definitely living in a simulation
as far as whether the physical world the
simulation in the sense that like was it
designed by it something outside of it
that tinkered with it to make it as it
is I suspect no I don't have a great I
don't think anyone has a great reason
for suspecting yes or no I'd say I'd
suspect no mostly on spiritual grounds
just the the fact that so many mystics
throughout the ages have had intense
experiences with what they felt with
strong conviction was ultimate reality
it's obviously not scientific evidence
but it's very interesting yeah all right
and how about what is the most beautiful
thing in the world I've sort of been
easy and somewhat basic answer this
would be music I I spend a lot of time
listening to music and it's one of the
most sort of aesthetically important
things
to me in my life yeah sure about why
interesting I think music is able to
invoke emotion extremely strongly even
when those emotions aren't necessarily
like what you're feeling in the moment a
sad song can really make you sad
anything that's a very beautiful thing
or a happy song can really make you
happy or a song that makes you feel
revolutionary can really make you feel
revolutionary and that's very cool
also hmm yeah I think in large part it's
because of the emotionality of it but
also there's a more abstract quality to
it that is hard to put my finger on but
it has to do with the fact that it's
very absorbed it can absorb you into it
in almost meditative way at least for me
I'm not I'm sure that's a experience
some people have and some people don't
have but it can make me unconcerned with
my current whatever's going on and fully
pay attention to it and there are very
few other things except maybe like a
phenomenal book or something that can
really make me pay attention to the
details in the way that music can yeah I
definitely agree with JJ about the power
of music for me the most beautiful thing
that there is is the ability to
consciously experience the present
moment I I guess a lot of my
appreciation for this comes from having
read the power of now back when I was
seventeen but I think that the the mind
is constantly imposing whether we
realize it or not a huge huge filter on
our conscious experience we selectively
pick out certain stimuli in the
environment and we focus on those
exclusively at the expense of the sort
of broader totality of our conscious
experience and I think that a lot of
that filter
stems from the
sort of attachment that we have
psychologically to the flow of time
we're constantly thinking about the
future about planning for things and
we're also constantly thinking about the
past ruminating regretting and so on and
so forth
oftentimes our attention is not
completely rooted inside the present
moment there is a beautiful beautiful
moment when you realize that your entire
life has been experienced in the present
there is nothing that has occurred for
you outside the present even the act of
sort of anticipating the future or
regretting the past happens in the
present and that's a very very deeply
liberating feeling it's not something
that's easy to communicate through words
or intellectually it's really something
that you just sort of have to experience
for yourself and I god it just it just
fills you with the utmost on wonder for
how beautiful the universe is and how
beautiful life is how great answers you
guys this has been such an awesome
episode I've loved talking to you both
you guys are young and ambitious and
pursuing such a critical field of
pushing the edge we're gonna do this
together
JJ Kenneth thank you guys so much for
coming on to the show huge thank you to
both of you such an honor and we love
smart young people let's get more smart
young people building around the world
everyone let's push them let's motivate
them let's get them executing and making
our world a better place let's give them
the right mentors the right resources
that they need to succeed the right
basic physiological needs is so so
critical I want to thank you all for
tuning in huge thank you would love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
let us know your thoughts psychedelics
consciousness spirituality oneness
neuroscience let's get talking to our
families our communities our co-workers
people online about it get sharing these
messages around the world let's do it
everyone check out the links below
definitely sign up
for their the club's mailing list to
Harvard undergraduate science of
psychedelics club their mailing list
link is below it's bit dot ly forward
slash Harvard - psychedelics also all of
JJ and Kenneth's links are in the bio
below as well check them out support the
artists entrepreneurs and organizations
around the world that you believe in
support them help them grow support
simulation our links are below us also
continue doing cool things like coming
to Cambridge and doing interviews and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world we love you
so much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon
peace